[Musique]
moi si j'étais un homme
je serai capitaine
d'un baratin vert et blanc
sera
et plus fort que les bennes
pour les trop mauvais temps
[Musique]
t'emmènerai en voyage
voir les plus beaux pays du monde
ferait l'amour sur la plage en savourant
chaque seconde
mon corps engourdissant flammes jusqu'à
s'endormir dans tes bras
va revenir quand on
on ne dit pas ces choses-là
[Musique]
t'offrirai pour qui joue
des fleurs pour ton appartement
des parfums à vous rendre fou et juste à
côté de
une ville qu'on appelle vergal je te
ferai construire une ville et je suis
fan et quand on est parole on n'achète
pas c'est chose là
[Musique]
il faut dire que les temps changent
et de nos jours
c'est chacun pour soi
ces histoires
d'amour des mots
[Musique]
on devient et comme
c'est dommage
moi j'aurais bien
un peu plus
du monde et de tendresse
les hommes
n'étaient pas si pressé
de prendre mes traits
ah si je t'aime je
[Musique]
t'appellerai tous les jours
rien que pour entendre ta voix
je t'appellerai mon amour
insisterait pour qu'on se voit est
inventerait un programme
à l'allure d'un soir de gala
pas mais quand on
est pas ces choses-là ne se prend pas
[Musique]
il faut dire que les temps changée
et de nos jours
c'est chacun pour soi
histoire
d'amour est ma vie
m'arrive qu'au cinéma
on devient et comme
c'est
[Musique]
dommage moi j'aurais bien aimé
oui un peu plus du monde et de tendresse
si les hommes
n'étaient pas si
presque une pendre des Princes
ainsi j'étais dans une
âme je serai romantique
[Musique]
je serai
roman
[Musique]